jjs 11 ok alex wie alex v oder dass
schüler mit einem scheck basierten
haaren übersicht ich lieber bis auf
youtube schon seit 2003 macht das immer
noch scheiße sagt mir wann wir zu sein
denn in der jugend bekannt
im ganzen land nur talent blues geringe
arbeitsaufwand youtube läuft gut oder
überhaupt nicht denkst du baden in
kammern sagte besserer ausstattung trend
es daher kein bisschen self mit stärke
macht noch mehr was da auf jedem video
über 100000 krieg doch bei dem
vierfachen abos ist das eigentlich ein
witz ich kann ich klar auf dich er ist
ein vorzeige [ __ ] und ja stimmt
was ihre freundin
naja
du bist du denkst du bist echt
nein
dich deine schauerlich deine schuhe
laut jetzt mal ganz ehrlich es haben
schon so viele die roscor safe challenge
gemacht und sich dabei selber fertig
gemacht und ich finde es auch wirklich
wichtig über sich selber lachen zu
können
doch mehr hat diese plattform schon so
viel ermöglicht und ich habe so viel
zeit investiert deshalb nenne ich meinen
zweiten fahrrad einfach nicht raus
yourself sondern jetzt mal push your
self jamann
ich erinnere mich zurück als ich gerade
15 war kleiner typs auf die zwölf wegen
meines vertrags klar in der schule
ausgelacht wird diabetes packe ein alter
weg nach oben alt war kein einzel machte
ja der anfang war hart ich hätte auf
gelächter
mein selbstbewusstsein amazon oder auch
kein stückchen besser ersten kanal zu
gemacht ich glaube dass sie weiß doch
ein ganzes jahr später drückt sich doch
heute ganz plötzlich leicht diese zahl
50.000 abo zeigt das ganze leider nur
durch abgefälschte sollten denkt doch
jeder anfang ist vorbei ein mensch
buseck
du bist ein
du denkst du besteck
mit deiner frau kleiner
hier stehe ich meine jetzt stelle ich
deine chance
jetzt bin ich da wo ich immer hinwollte
aber eine sache will ich noch loswerden
also passt mal auf ich habe gekämpft von
keinem etwas sagen lasst dann fanden
sich zwei menschen die perfekt
zusammenpassen danke für alles klappt
die allerbeste freundin und dann alle
die mich hassen
doch das erstmal bis hier so leute ich
bin hat extra noch rausgegangen um die
end karte für euch zu drehen auf jeden
fall hofft natürlich es hat euch ein
bisschen unterhalten und der song
gefällt euch so einigermaßen also ich
persönlich fahre jetzt am ende ganz cool
das video finde ich auch gelungen
schreibt eure meinung in die kommentare
und was auf jeden fall noch nach oben
wenn es euch gefällt wenn ich könnte
natürlich auch gerne daumen nach unten
da lassen auf jeden fall jetzt erstmal
danke schön an kasper für den refrain
für deine stimme hat mich persönlich
mega gefreut checkt auf jeden fall mal
caspers channel ab da ist das making of
und lassen doch nach oben da da noch
dankeschön ein armband für den beat und
du hast du kannst ja abgemischt auch
wirklich fertig dankeschön dankeschön an
willen dass das musikvideo für mich
gedreht hat steckt auch auf jeden fall
mal den channel ab der auch mega fettes
videoausgang und zwei aus träume ist
auch in der videos verlinkt nur uns
echter vorbeizuschauen und danke auch an
sebastian 1 sebastian auf youtube für
den schnitt auch hier hat sich so
ergeben habe ich mich gefreut ich bin
zufrieden und ich gehe jetzt nach hause
und geschlafen und ich freue mich darauf
morgen das video für euch hoch zu
bauland peace